the jeep that we're going to take a look
at is a 1979 Jeep Cheroke key that my
wife purchased for me after my dad
passed away she caught me looking at it
online said hey let's get out of here we
flew to Phoenix Arizona and drove it
back uh to Nashville it was all original
at the time and had uh you know like
77,000 Mi on it and I warned her that we
would not make it all the way and we did
we did lose an alternator along the way
but since it made its way back home she
kind of regifted it to me as uh in a way
that she kind of hooked it up for some
guys at hendri racing to kind of redo
the whole thing so it's as modern as it
can be mechanically and every nut bolt
and screw on it is either refurbished or
new so it's a thing that I can get
inside and once again have lot of grave
memories it's special to me in ways that
I could never get rid of it and
hopefully never wreck in it